If you are still
using Firebase for the back end of your project,
then consider yourself making a big mistake
because there are many
paid features in Firebase like cloud functions, storage
limit, back end deployment and many advanced
things due to which you have to pay money again and again.
But now this is not going to happen at all.
Because in this video I am going to
tell you about the best alternative of Fireweb
where you will get all these features
completely free.  Yes, I am
talking about super bass here.  With Super Base,
you can create a powerful, free back up for a mobile app, web app, or even a full
website.
That too without any hidden charges
and there was a lot of demand from some of you to
bring a full course on Super Base.  So
in this video I will teach you step by step
super base setup, back end creation and creation of a
full stack powerful admin application.
That too in a single video.
So don't make the mistake of skipping this video.
And if you want me to
teach you how to create your own professional backend using C-Panel in the next video, then make sure this video reaches 1000 likes.
So let's start without wasting any time.   So
let's learn how to create our own application using Superb.
First of all
you have to come to the browser and then search
Super Base.  After this
you have to open this first number website.  Let
me tell you in advance that this is
not a sponsored video.
I am making this video on your demand.
Talking about Superb, Superb is a back end
provider.  Like Firebase, it provides us the backend for all the
framework applications and coding
projects.
Like Firebase does.  And just
like Firebase, we get to
see a readymade back end here.  Meaning
we don't need to build a custom back end.
We can easily create
our application website whatever your
project is by using the back end of Superb.
And I think the best part of Super Base is
that its first plan is
available to watch free of cost.  On which you
also get to see 1GB of storage.
But we have to pay something to enable storage on FireB.
So if we
talk about our free plan, then API can
send unlimited.  At least
we can keep 500 users active monthly.
And talking about the database size,
we get 500 GB of storage
to store the database with 500 GB of RAM.  And
talking about storage, we get to see 1GB of
storage which
we get to see free of cost.
And there are some limitations
in the free plan like you can create two projects
and if there is no activity in your project within one week then
it will automatically pause.  So if you are
getting so much in the free plan then it is enough.
Now if you scroll down here, you
can see that React Native, Flutter, and
Quickland are supported by almost all frameworks, including
React and Flutter.  Now let's start setting up the back end.
So first of all
you have to authenticate through your GetUp account
or
create your account through email.  After this
you have to come to the dashboard.  When you
authenticate for the first time, you will
see an interface like this.  Here
we have to give the name.
You can also type the company name.  I'll leave a random one here.
After this we will
select type as personal.  After this we will select the free plan.
Click on Create Organization.  After the organization is created,
we have to
enter the name of the project here.  Whatever you
want to make the project.  So we
want to build an expansion tracker app using Flutter.
So the name has been entered here.  After this
we will have to enter the database password here.
So we can select a strong password.
Or you can also do it.
After entering the password,
we have to select the religion here.  So here we will
select our nearby location
so that we get fast database speed.
So we have selected our location.
I have selected South Asia Mumbai here.
Now after this we will
click on Create New Project.  So
a new project will be created on our super base.
Ok.  So our project has been successfully created on Super Base.
Now let's
talk about the features of the side bar.  So here
we start with the table editor.  So the
table editor is here for us to see.  In
which we
can see our database in table format.  You can edit it together.
SQL editor is also
available here.  On which you
can enter your SQL queries
and create your database.
And on the database you will get the proper to see the database of your project.   If you
come to Authentication, you will get to
see the list of all authenticated users here
and you
can create buckets of your application or project on the storage.
Where you can store your project media
type content or document type content
whatever you
want to store.  And in edge function you
can basically create server less function back end logic API.  Along with back
end verification, you can create custom business logic.
And talking about real time database,
we use real time database for live
data syncing, chatting applications, live
dashboard or notifications.
We also get to see this free of cost on Superb.
And the remaining features are
for documentation and external service database management.  Now let us know
how we can connect the back end of Superb to the front end project.  So
here you will find the option on the header Connect.   If you
come here then you have to come here App
Framework.  So you will get to
see all the frameworks here.  Whoever
you want to connect with.  If you
want to connect to Vacant for mobile applications,
then here you will get to
see all the mobile frameworks.
Whether it is native or cross
and if we want the API of this project
then we can also see it here
and if we want to connect it with MCP then
MCP is also available here and
we will setup our back end only by using MCP.   There
is also manual method but I would recommend
that you go with MCP because
in MCP our back end is automatically
generated.  Now let us
understand a lot about the back end.  Now let's come to the
front end and create our front end project.  Then
after this we will understand
how we can connect our front end project with the back end of Superbase.  So
for the front end you
can create any project to test.  If you
want to go into web application then you can
create project on React or if you want then you can create project on Next GS.  Or if you
want to go into mobile application then you can
create it in React or Flutter whichever you like.  So
I would like to move to Flutter.   Let
me show you how to create a new project with Flutter.
So here
we will select Flutter New Project.
After this, select the empty application.
Also, we will select the folder that we have
created for our project
here.  Now after this
we will enter the name of our project here.
We want to build an expansion tracker application.
So I have
entered his name here.  If we click on enter then
our project will be created.
Now we will just wait a little.
While our project is being created.
Until we understand
what features our applications will have.
So we are going to create an expansion tracker application
which will be
supported for both web and mobile applications and will be
responsive design.  If I
talk directly about the features here, then we are going to have a
super clean user interface on our application
in which we will use iOS native Material to
build the application.  And
talking about screen by features, our
application will have splash screen along with
login and authentication system
screen.  When the user completes authentication
through email and password.
To sign up, the user will have to enter his/her details.
Such as full name, email,
password, confirm password.  After this, if the
user clicks on the sign up button, he can
create his account on our application.
After that he will have to do email verification.
After this he can login.
After logging in, the user will
see a screen with a bottom navigation
bar.  Basically there will be a home screen and
below it there will be a bottom navigation bar.
Talking about the features of the home screen, there will be
some features of the expansion tracker like
text for welcome.  The Quick
Actions and Previews feature will be an expansion list.  There will
also be analytics cards and a feature to add new expansions.  There will be a
tab to track expansions
in our application on the bottom navigation bar and there will
also be a profile section which will have basic features.
Like all the details of the user will be
visible.  Along with this, there will be
some
basic features for UR customization to customize the application.  Features like font size
and dark light mode color theme and
this is the database structure that is to be present
in our application.  Now let's
learn to create this application
with a superb package.  Our project has been
successfully created here.  Now
we will connect our code editor through SuperBase's MCP.
I'm
using anti-gravity here.  If you want,
whatever you use like cursor windows or VS Code,
MCP is supported on all of them.  We are
using anti-gravity here.  So we'll
come to the three dots here.  We
will go to MCP servers and here we will simply search for
Super Base and if such feature is not
available on any code editor then you
also get the option of configuration.
I have explained it in many videos.  You
can watch previous videos in which
I have explained proper NCP installation.
Now after this we will install the MCP of Super Base.
Here we have to
enter the access token.  So we'll click here.
Now from here we have to generate a new token.
You can name it anything.  And after this you also have to select the expiry date as to
when your token will
expire.  So we select 30 days.
And make sure you do
n't have to share this token with anyone.  Otherwise, your
entire Super Base account access will
fall into someone else's hands.  So you do
n't have to share this.
Consider this access token as access to your entire account.
Now
we will paste the access token here and click on save.
After clicking on Save, we may have to
wait a little here.  Okay, so
our token has been applied.  Now we will
restart AntiGravity once
so that our MCP gets
connected properly.  Now let's check if
our MCP is connected or not.  So
we'll come back here.  Here we will
click on Manage MCP Servers.  So you
can see here that our MCP has been
enabled.  Now you have to come back to
PRD.  After coming to PRD,
wherever you have created your structure, you have to
come there in your PRD.  So
this is our date structure which
we had generated in PRD.  If
you do not know how to make PRD then you
can watch previous videos.
I will also give you the link in the description so that
you will learn to make professional and detailed PRD.
After this,
we will write this here in PRD so that our
code editor can understand that we have already
connected the MCP of Superb.  You have to
call our backend using the MCP on
which we have already created our
Expansion Tracker application project
and within that you have to
setup the backend and prepare the SQL queries.
Authentication
system also has to be used.  When the back end is
complete then you have to start the front end.
Whatever I told you, I have
typed it here in English.  Now
we will just copy this completely PRD.
After copying the PRD, we will
come here to main dot dot.  I'll
tag my main dot dot on composer.  Along with
our dependency file and after this we
will paste the PRD and here we will
select the mode fast.  You
can select the model you want.  I will
select Cloudic 4.5 Thinking here, you
can select whatever you like.  After this we will
send it and just wait.  So you
can see here that our code editor has
called our MCP and has detected our
project that was created in the back end.
Now if
we come back here, we will see
that our database is
starting to get setup.  So we wait a little bit
until our data waits
okay.  So our back end setup
is ready in just a few seconds which would have taken us hours to do.
Now here we
will refresh the page once and check whether
our structure is ready or not.  So
you can see that our
structure has been successfully prepared.  Now if we
come to the tables here, our tables would also have been
created.  You can see on the side bar that
all our tables are ready.  If
we click on Users here,
you can see here that the User table has opened.
Now, similarly, the data of all the users
who will use our application will be stored here
and if we come back here and
see, our front end has started getting created here.
So first of all our
models are created.  After this, the
expansion model is being created.  Now let
us just wait a little.
OK, our expansion tracker application
is ready in just a few seconds.  Let's
first try running it on the web.  So
I selected Chrome here.
Now let's run it and see.
Okay, our application has been successfully run
and I had asked to create a responsive design
in PID.  So, it will be
responsive for both desktop and mobile.
Now let me show you on mobile.  So,
here we go on mobile.  So, you
can see that there is responsive design for mobile as well.
Now let us first sign up
and check whether we are
able to see the same data on our back end as is
visible on the front end or not.  So, let me
quickly fill in my details here.
Okay, I have filled in the details here.
Now let's click on Sign Up.  Sign
up is not happening because now we have to do email
verification which would have come on our email.
So let's refresh the email once.
So you can see here that a recent
message has come.  Now let us confirm here.
After this we will login and see.
Ok.  So, this is what the interface looks like.  This
means that our email verification has been done
because currently we are running on local host, that is why it
is showing like this.  Now
we login here.  Ok.  So our
Expansion Trackon application is working and
we are now logged in.  Now let us
check on the back end.  Here we
refresh once.  Let's see if we get to
see that email or not.  We have
authenticated through this email.  Now
let's see if this data is visible here
or not.  So you can see that
this is what we had given in full name and this is the email.  Along with this,
time date is also available to see everything.
Now let's try adding some expansions as well.
Now here we type the category.
So let me type home here
and budget it to 1000.
Ok.  After this we will keep the date as today.
Description nothing.  We create.
Ok.  So our expansion has been successfully
created.  Now let's check in the back end
whether it has been created or not.
So let's come to the back end.  Here we go to the
expansion tables.  No, I have to come here.
So you can see here that the
expansion that we have added is visible in our back end.
From here we
can track all the expansions and
from Profile we can manage our profile.
And
we have not used any real time database to create this application.
Only normal database has been
used.  And just like this is a normal database
, similarly ours is a real time database.
But now we can use the storage here.
So we will also learn to use storage.
We have also taken care of authentication.
Now let's refresh once and see what
we get to see here.
We did the authentication through that email.
So you can see here that the
email we used is
available here in authentication.  Along with this, we
can also see the status whether the email for which authentication has been done is
verified or not.  So it
is verified, enabled and from here we
can also reset its password.
If the user does not want to reset the
password of the user, we can reset it ourselves.
Along with this, there are other features like deleting the user, banning them etc.
Now let us
learn how to use storage in our application and
how we can use storage
in our application.  If your
application has any media type content
and want to store it or
want to create an uploading system then how will it be done.   I
understood the use of database and authentication.
But if you have an application
that needs to display media type content
or create an uploading system,
how can you create it?  So for that
we will need storage.  So
now I am going to teach you how to do that.
As you know we have an
expansion tracking application where
we click on add expansion.  So
we should have an option to upload an image here.
So I will simply
come here to composer and enter this prompt here
and tell it to
create a bucket in the back end
for storage using MCP.  Along with this, there should
also be an option to upload images in place of add expansion so that
storage usage will be reduced in our application.  This is just
for example, I am explaining to
you how to use it.  Ok?  So now we will
tag all the files here and
drop them on the composer and send them.
Now our MCP tool and our AI
code editor will take care of everything.  So you
can see here that our code editor has
called MCB so that our storage will be
created.  A bucket will be created
in our back end.  Let's check now.
So let's come to storage.  Once we refresh the
page.  I think it must have been created.
No, it hasn't happened yet.  We will have to
wait a bit.  Now let's check by
refreshing once.  Whether our storage create
bucket has been created or not.  So you
can see here that our bucket has been successfully
created.  On which media files with this type of
extension can be uploaded.  The
minimum size will be 5 MB.  Now it
depends on your application that
what type of extension media
file or any other type of file the user uploads.  You
can also get it done as PDF.  You
can also get MP4 done.
Ok.  So all the changes have been applied.
Now let's do the testing.  So I've
run it on a virtual device.  Here it is.
Now let's log in.  After this we
upload and check whether the uploading system is working
or not.
OK, we have successfully logged in.  Now let's
add a new one.  From here we
select our image.  I had already
downloaded one.  I'll show you on the browser.
I had downloaded this image.  Let me
select it to show you.  The
email has been uploaded successfully.
Now let me quickly go over the details here.
Ok.  So I have
filled all the details here.  Now let's
create the expansion.  I have clicked on create.
Image has also been uploaded along with it.
So the image is visible here but it is
not of that size.  Rest we can make it of size.
Now let us check in the back end
whether the image we have uploaded has been
stored or not.  So, we'll
come to the back end.  Here we
select the storage.  After this, we simply open this
folder that has been created, this bucket that has been created.
Okay,
here the bucket is open.  Let's open the folder.
I think our image should be inside it.  Let's
click
on this image here.  So, you can see that the same image which
we uploaded to our application
from the front end has successfully reached the back end.
And
I will also let you check the second expansion that has been added.  So, we'll
come to the tables here and from here we'll check.
So you can see that the
expansion that we had added is
also available to be seen successfully here.   This
means that our back end is
working perfectly and you have also understood
how the authentication storage database works.
Now as far as real time database is concerned,
I don't need to explain it much.  It is similar to the
database we just used.  The
only difference is that the
database we have just used does
not provide real time updates.  For that we have to
refresh the application or our website.
Whatever project you are
creating, be it a website or an application,
we will have to refresh it.  But it
gives updates in real time database without refreshing.  That's the only
difference.  But there was
no such use in our application.  So
I haven't.  Rest of the integration is almost the same
for both.  And here in the
database, we only get to
see the structure.
Here we get to see the proper structure of our back end database.
And here in the table editor
we can see our structure in detail tables
wise.  Like we
see sections on Firebase.  You can understand those collections as these
and the data inside the sections as these
tables.  Just a little
different here.  The rest is the same thing.  And
here if we talk about functions, you can
create your own function.  Which
you can deploy.  You can create your own back-end
generating system like AI
or integrate it into the payment process.
Whatever your heavy back end is, you
can deploy it in the function.  So that
you will not have to write external code in the application.
You can also deploy the back end of
your entire application here.
Now let me show you how to become an admin of this application.
So first of all,
wherever our project is, we will
open the folder there.  After that we will
create a new folder of admin.  So I have
created a new folder here.
After this, we will import the
same folder which we have created for admin on our Anti Gravity
and also
we will create a new project of Flutter inside it.
So here we type admin as the
name of this application.  Ok.  So
our project has been created and
I have added both our admin and user side applications in the same workspace.
Now from here we will
delete the unnecessary folders which are
not needed and for which platforms we are
not creating the application.  So
we will remove it from both admin and user side.
Now after this we will select the main dot dot of adminman here
and after tagging it on the composer, we will
paste this prop and
tell it to
give us full control of our back end to the admin
so that we can manage our application completely.
So I
typed in 'pt' here.  He has
also asked to take full control.  And
if there is a need for back end in our admin, then
I have also said
in the prompt that you can verify the back end by calling MCP.
Now now
we will just send it here.  But before that we will
tag some more files here.
Like we will tag the model files here
so that our back end can understand it better
and now let's send it.  Now our admin
dashboard will start getting created.  Now let
us just wait a little.
OK, our admin is ready.  Now let's
run Android Dot on our virtual
Android.
OK our APK has been successfully built.
Our OK.  So here you can see that
our admin is running successfully.
Our expansions are available to see here.
Along with this, users, we had
logged in through email ID which can be
seen here.   It is
properly working.
Check other things as well.  Here you can
see the complete analytics dashboard.  If we
go to expansions,
we have added these expansions on the user side, then the
admin can also see them here and
can also delete them.  From here we
can refresh.  If you look in storage, you
can see the images here.  It is loaded
on our back end, you will get to see it properly here
and if I show the user side application, then
this is our user side
application which is working properly.
No one has any issue with this either.  Now you
can see here that the expansion was not
visible earlier.  Now here we can
track properly.  So it is so easy to create
your project using the back end of Substus.
So there was a lot of demand from you guys to
make a video on Super Base in which
you teach how to make the entire back end setup, front
end, everything from scratch.  So
in this video I taught you everything from creating a complete full
stack application to setting up the back end.
If you
still have any doubts, you
can tell me by commenting or if you have a big problem,
you can DM me on Instagram.
I will help you completely
and I will give the link of the source code of this application in the
description of the video.  So
you can go and download it.  You can try it yourself also.
So I hope you
found this video inspiring.  If you found it inspiring,
please don't forget to press the like button and
for more such videos, please subscribe to the channel
because at this time I really
need your support.  It takes
me a lot of time to make such videos.
So please make sure like and
subscribe.  See you in the next video.
Thanks for watching.  And
what will be the next topic?  Please let me know by commenting.